les électeurs arrivent au compte gouttes
ils ne sont pas très nombreux regardez
sur ce tableau le début des opérations
de vote sur ces images de claire nico à
8h37 donc avec un peu plus d'une demi
heure de retard dans ce bureau de vote
seuls quatre électeurs ont voté ils ont
déposé leurs bulletins dans cette urne
qui est scellée qui a été scrutée avec
attention par les observateurs des
observateurs qui poursuivent leurs
travaux dans les différents bureaux de
vote du lycée sainte marie de cocody ont
rejoint une électrice qui attend son
tour pour voter dans le bureau d'à côté
madame vous allez vous apprêtez à
exercer votre devoir civique dans un
climat c'est vrai de tension la
motivation elle est encore là oui la
motivation encore là les gens viennent
contrairement à ce qu'on pensait les
électeurs arrivent pour voter alors je
suis contente et je les remercie et je
vous remercie vous aussi les agents de
la presse un de franck hervé rubin pour
interpol interview de ces élections
ça c'est ma carte d'électeur de la
montrer oui je suis fier de la monterie
alors cette carte d'électeur ils sont
300 millions à la voir sur 7,5 millions
d'électeurs inscrits on attend donc le
président sortant alassane ouattara je
voulais dit vers 11 heures heure locale
le président qui n'avait pas prévu de se
représenter pour cette élection mais là
le décès d'amadou gon coulibaly son
successeur désigné et ancien premier
ministre en juillet dernier a changé la
donne depuis l annonce de sa candidature
pour un troisième mandat que
l'opposition juge anticonstitutionnelle
et bien le pays replonge dans un cycle
de violence on déplore au moins une
trentaine de morts des violences dites
intercommunautaires que le pouvoir
imputé à l'opposition et l'opposition au
pouvoir
sur les quatre candidats deux boycottent
l'élection plus tôt ils disent qu'il n'y
a pas d'élection aujourd'hui il s'agit
de l'ancien président henri konan-bédié
et de pascal affi n'guessan du f pays
il y en a un qui veut en tout cas
aujourd'hui avec alassane ouattara
c'est le plus jeune des candidats
kouadio konan bertin âgé de 51 ans il
vote à 200 km d'abidjan
l'enjeu ce n'est pas de savoir qui va
remporter ce scrutin parce que le
président alassane ouattara devrait
s'imposer si on arrive au bout de cette
journée de vote qui a débuté avec
beaucoup de retard l'opposition a appelé
à un boycott des actifs à la
désobéissance civile cela veut dire que
elle va tout faire pour stopper les
opérations de vote
stopper ce scrutin elle sait que 35
mille hommes qui sont déployés dans le
cadre de l'opération barrissement de
l'éléphant pour sécuriser les plumes
plus de 22 mille bureaux de vote
répartis dans onze milieu
en côte d'ivoire ce sera difficile donc
elle compte profiter de cette marge de
manoeuvre pour être active à l'intérieur
du pays dans ses principaux fiefs d'où
la crainte
effectivement deux heures aujourd'hui en
tout cas la capitale abidjan
comme la plupart des grandes villes
devrait rester stable et sécurisé on va
quand même scruter les quartiers les
plus défavorisés
ici à abidjan par exemple le quartier de
yopougon et puis on scrutera aussi le
taux d'abstention comme je voulais dire
les militants arrive véritablement au
compte gouttes
ici un taux d'abstention qui devrait
être élevé en raison du climat
sécuritaire et de la paye de l'appel au
boycott